deep in the heart of the Andes Mountains
one man is growing lots and lots and
lots of potatoes no kata guruma money no
Honda no Palin kamiki Papa's Neto esta
casa cuatro Vientos Barak tantos mocha
Papa Panov suit inta William safety
pokazhi pokazhi pokazhi Palma making
attempts by the Dance Moms
[Music]
Jericho Anita
kanata lasagna with responsive about the
holy water
[Music]
potatoes originated along the southern
border of Peru close to 8,000 years ago
Julio lives near where potato growth
first thrived in one of the most remote
locations in the country mocha the
energy common era campus in a bumper
crop a pertinent Cusco for renewal after
own mill artisans named emer Altos
lettuce lettuce man compare and jacket
the portico Julio's family has lived in
the region for generations and thanks to
the lands microclimate he's able to grow
his unique potatoes in high quantities
Julio is always experimenting with new
farming techniques and relies on other
native potato farmers to create his new
strains open o commence at 11:00 como
arranger symbolic token Angela and
Watson can be M&M equivalent compliment
as children as well as cotton municipal
[Music]
mekka missions of the diario even mañana
Dolphy in the third club the same choppa
choppa
saenko but Gustavo Mihama master muscle
mean to Kathleen of among Gustavo
Minmatar says most protein propitiated
not a peaceful manner
tanto coefficient repeat Lancaster
repeats and many potatoes are not only a
staple in Julio's diet they are the
backbone of Peruvian cuisine which is
why Julio wants to push the boundaries
of potato farming and continue his
family's legacy nokotta nokotta taco
non-st Annabelle periodically papa
Cory Ronnie is perpetually managing a
number
[Music]
you
[Music]